رحله علم ملهمه بطلتها سيده حاربت المرض
والاميه معا حققت حلمها بمناقشه رساله
الماجستير بعد ان تمت الثمانين عاما امال
اسماعيل وقفت في محطات عده منذ زواجها
وانشغالها بتربيه
ابناء اصابتها بمرض السرطان مرتين لكن
تيته امال ضربت لنا مثالا على الاصرار فلم
تنشغل بالتعليقات السلبيه واكملت مشوارها
بين صفوف الطلاب الذين في اعمار احفادها
طلاب جمعتهم معها علاقه طيبه يساعدونها
ويطمئنون عليها ان غابت عن المدرجات وهي
الان لم تقف هنا بل تستعد لاستكمال
المسيره وتحضير رساله الدكتوراه
يعني اولا نبدا بشعورك كيف كان شعورك بعد
ان حصلتي على رساله الماجستير بعد هذا
المشوار الطويل الف مبارك بتقدير امتياز
كمان الحمد لله هذا من فضل ربي وبعدين ما
تنسوش ان انا هو ما اضافنيش جديد لان اصلا
ده حلم نايم جوه قلبي من زمان من وانا
طفله فهو كل الموضوع انك كانك جبت طفل
خرجتيه من السرير طلعتيه تشوفيه وتبوسيه
وتحبيه يعني احنا عايزين نقول لك الف
مبروك كمان ومنورانا في الصباح في صباح
العربيه على شاشه العربيه هذا اولا انتوا
اللي منورين هنا والله انتم منورين انا
كمان تسلمي طيب كمان شغله يعني على 38 انت
خلصتي مدرسه لا خلصتي اعداديه يعني خلص
صار لك قعدت سنين
ما تعلمتي طب بهذول السنين شو كان شو راح
عليك فيهم ليه اخذتك لل80 لتكم جايه اي ست
بيت عاديه تطبخ لعيالها تذاكر لهم تعمل
لهم لاكثر ولا اقل يعني
ركزت على البيت يعني والاولاد ايوه ايوه
ما هو كان ده شرط زوج ان انا ما اخرجش بره
البيت عشان
اسيب الاولاد واروح اتعلم طيب تيته امال
بعدها رحله قلت انها استغرقت ثلاث سنين
مليئه بالصعوبات نجحتي في مناقشه رساله
ماجستير وبتفوق شو ابرز الصعوبات اللي
واجهتك تتعمل ما فيش عندي صعوبات واجهتني
ان انا مرضت بالكورونا جت قعدتنا سنه ما
كناش بنروح الكليه ولا نتحرك زائد ان انا
اصبت بكسر في الحوض
في السنه التمهيدي لماجستير
فقعدت ست شهور زائد سنه يبقى سنه وست شهور
من ثلاث سنين يعني يعتبر ان انا خلصته في
وقت قياسي يعني اكيد يعني هو بامتياز طب
يا تيته امال كل واحد بالحياه عنده
اهتمامات توجهات انت ليه اخترتي كليه
الاداب بالذات علشان كنت بحبها لان منها
نجيب محفوظ الله يرحمه طه حسين نجيب محفوظ
برضو الله يرحمه امينه السعيد سهير
القلماوي يعني يوسف ادريس كان طبيب بس انا
كنت بحب كتابته يعني يعني معظم اللي بحبه
اللي بحبهم خريجي كليه اداب
[تصفيق]